Cô Splayer, Bộ Mét, Bộ Mét sau tối tại Bình Hoa Siu Thực, sắp nhận xuất hiện tại ngày hội ghên lớn nhất Việt Nam sắp tới.
Mến thị Hà Vy, 2 còn được biết đến Tối Bình Xanh Vy Vh 1, là một trong những vương mặt nổi bật trong cộng đồng Cô Splay tinh Nam nhờ phản năng Việt thoát ấn tự và phong cách khoa trang tình đế.
Hện khô năng xử hiệu hơn 8,5 mình người theo dõi trên các nền tàng mạng xác hội và hơn 7,5 mũ mức tương nghi lưu tích trên thích tốt, những có số thiện hiện sự cuối không nhỏ của cố chong rồi trẻ yêu thích Cô Splay.
Từ khi còn là nước sinh, Hà Vy tương kây báo cộng đồng mạng chỉ với một đoàn clip dài ma zây nhiều về đẹp như buc bề.
Chính phẩy ngoài ngọt nào ở đã đưa cô đến với thế giới Cô Splay sau một lần tham dự lễ hội phản hóa nhất ở năm 2019.
Chai với phy ngoài mông mạnh, Hà Vy lại làm hử dức đột lập.
Từ thời cấp bà, cô đã làm thêm để tự đưa tư cho những bộ đồ Cô Splay có khi lên đến cả trục trộ đồng mạc hô phụ thuộc cộng sẽ đi.
Dù chỉ ca một mết 1 mì sấu, nhưng Hà Vy luôn biết các chiếm cho sốt lại qua mỗi đức anh nhiều điều cảm tốt và thân thái đặc trường.
Cô tường hóa thân thành loạt nhân bật đình đám như Mà Vy tà, Nà Via, Europe, Europe, Europe, và luôn khiến cộng đồng trường trộ vì sự đô tư chính tru và khi trước trình nhân bật.
Dù không tham gia quá nhiều sự kiện, Hà Vy vẫn đều đạn chiếc xẻ sân phẩm lên mạng sớ hội và gắn bói khuy cộng đồng Cô Splay.
Tại Việt Nam, game boost hành hỉ khu trong hai mấy lắm, Cô Sé sức hiện với Phải Chòo giám thảo khác mời cho vọng bình trọn Cô Splay Contest,
hứa hệ hạn mang đến những góc nhìn truyền muôn và tình đế.